thank you
[__] down on your opponents and
seeing them as nothing and Unworthy of
respect has got to be one of anime's
stable moments and character archetypes
who doesn't like a competent character
that doesn't stop beating their opponent
in a way that humiliates them after all
why show respect to those lesser than
you from main characters to straight up
villains and antagonists this sort of
thing has something for everyone so Buck
it up because today we're looking at
some of anime's most disrespectful
moments
starting our list of disrespect is
Sasuke going up against killer bee
[Music]
we're talking about The Walking diss
track killer bee with his easy going and
chill personality combined with his
unorthodox way of fighting he was
quickly added to the anime Hall of Fame
with nothing else but swag alone his
battle against Sasuke was also a sight
to behold not only giving Sasuke a solid
beat down shattering his confidence but
also rhyming at the same time
[Applause]
and don't even get me started at the
moment he pours mid fight and wrote down
bars on his notebook while Sasuke was in
front of him I mean that's way to show
your opponents that they're not a threat
to you his Sharingan didn't do much
either Killer Bees weird fighting style
an unpredictable way of fighting proved
hard even for him to handle all in all
if it wasn't for Sasuke's allies behind
him I think it's safe to say he wouldn't
have made it into the sequel especially
when killer beat made a hole in his
chest damaging his organs which could
have been life-threatening if it wasn't
for Jugo Sasuke got humbled real quick
it doesn't help much either that he
almost died on multiple occasions in
this confrontation it's best you don't
mess with this guy while he's dropping
bars
next we have Gojo versus jogo from
Jujutsu Kaizen
if we're on the topic of disrespect we
can't just keep the overly confident
Gojo out of this list yeah he basically
has everything that you need to qualify
his overwhelming amount of Charisma and
Suave with the skills to back it up are
just the perfect combination for a
character that will certainly look down
on you after a battle literally and
figuratively especially in his battle
against jogo where this seemingly
confident Mountain Head took on Gojo by
himself on the eve of the battle the
power difference was pretty apparent
with Gojo Ragdoll and Joe go around as
if he was target practice and if this
isn't insulting enough he also bought
itadori along so he could use his
special grade curse opponent as a
makeshift Jiu Jitsu lesson Gojo
literally considered him too weak to be
a threat and instead turned him into a
PowerPoint presentation for domain
expansions he then proceeded to
decapitate jogo with his bare hands
along with a psychotic smile on his face
I don't think he was bluffing when he
said he could take on the king of curses
on his own and win but can he well in
conclusion Joker went home only with his
head intact but violated and embarrassed
so sounds about right
[Music]
now one of Hunter Hunter's iconic
moments
oh
hi we have two Psychopaths pitted
against each other kilua versus jonest
the dissector following the path of
majority rules during the third stage of
the 287th hunter exam a merry band of
characters found themselves going up
against five criminals residing within
the trick Tower in a series of
challenges the last fight was then up to
kilua where he was pitted against Jonas
in a simple but straightforward
challenge a head-on death match the
fight was fast and it was awesome in one
of the coldest anime scenes of all time
all of Jonas's useless bragging didn't
help him much as kilua lunges forward
and plucks his heart out even going as
far as wrapping it up in a little bag as
the humbled killer stumbles and falls to
the ground kirua just nonchalantly hands
him his heart back he may be a murderous
assassin psychopath but he's our
murderous assassin psychopath there's
not much to say about this fight but you
don't want to imagine a scenario where
kilua was an antagonist
is it all right
yeah
moving on to the classics now we have
one piece featuring Zorro versus mihawk
back when the series was just getting
started this fight was mind-blowing for
everyone to watch Zoro was established
beforehand to be a very capable fighter
but the subsequent fight that follows
really showed us how big the world of
one piece is and how there's always a
bigger fish out there with his four
boating entrance to the scene with his
dinghy boats Zorro didn't waste any time
and asked the renowned swordsman in a
jewel the disrespect comes not from the
fact that Zoro got bodied left right and
center but with the fact that mihawk did
it using what's basically a butter knife
implying the Zorro isn't even worth the
effort of him wielding his actual weapon
even going as far as apologizing for not
having a smaller weapon we're reaching
higher levels of disrespect with this
man and all of his Small Talk was
justifiable if his title of strongest
swordsman isn't evident enough mihawk
with no effort single-handedly gave Zoro
his most crushing defeat and his iconic
scar
s
[Music]
in the anime that has the most
interesting fan base we have shigaraki
king of villains and Decay against the
number one hero Endeavor at the high to
the Paranormal Liberation War the hype
and scenes just kept on upping each
other with scenarios and plot
developments that just took us by
surprise at times but we're focusing on
One Singular scene here and that was
when shigaraki faced off against
Endeavor and ryuku right after
shigaraki's Awakening and his casual
obliteration of a huge chunk of the city
with his now evolved a cake work he
decides to also obliterate endeavor's
Pride after slamming him into the ground
and making the same pose Endeavor did in
Kyushu and not only that he openly
mocked him even though there were
multiple heroes in the scene and a razor
head deactivated shigaraki's Quirk it
wasn't enough to stop this madman from
humiliating the current number one hero
who could have known that this emo they
just had too many hands gave the same
level of disrespect he had when he was a
kid now we're back at it again with the
classics we have izen versus Ichigo
on the eve of the battle Ichigo assisted
renji in somehow immobilizing Eisen they
weren't even thinking about the
possibility of them winning anymore what
matters is that they could Escape we
also got the usual power-up scene with
the theme music swelling up as Ichigo
charges at Eisen and just when his sword
made contact Eisen without moving with
minimal effort at all caught and stopped
not only his sword but also his theme
music eisendindin just flex and
disrespect him by nonchalantly stopping
his attack that the music hyped up so
much Eisen also copyright strikes that
very same theme music turning the scene
dead silent as Ichigo was then struck by
izen fatally injuring him oh God this
type of stuff was really surprising
especially in the earlier days of anime
due to how much he overthrew our
expectations back then this scene was
really iconic and took many of the fans
by surprise and despite the passage of
time and this scene still making it on
the list it just shows how much of a
threat izen really is as he laid a solid
groundwork for what he's capable of and
what he'll become later on all according
to plan
oh
oh yeah
the resident mad lad and wildcard
himself yujiro hanma all right I have to
be perfectly honest when it comes to
yujiro he just steals every scene he's
in whilst flipping the table on his head
due to the fact that he'd just do the
most outlandish and absurd thing and
then just promptly leave as if nothing
ever happened and that's exactly what
happened in this scene it wasn't even
that much of a fight but more of a
demonstration of power if you like
[Laughter]
as he shows up out of nowhere after
motto Bay and Yanagi conclude their
fight he walks up to motobe who was
wielding a sword and just casually
starts breaking it bit by bit slowly and
menacingly imagine how demoralizing that
must have been just staring hopelessly
at some Behemoth of a man just slowly
chips away at your weapon he then
proceeds to walk over to Yanagi as if he
didn't just give someone the most
terrifying moment in their life and
promptly leaves this is yujiro hanma's
world and we're just living in it a
short but sweet scene of yujiro just
showing everyone who's at the top of the
food chain I'm even willing to bet that
the animators didn't even intend for him
to be there but yujiro goes wherever he
pleases and I'm not stopping him
next up to take the stage in our list is
the night City Boogeyman himself Adam
Smasher
now when it comes to disrespect that he
quite literally means it for he thinks
of flesh is weak and he sees you as
nothing more than mere toys to break
that means he thinks of everyone lesser
than him not deserving of any form of
respect when David was going on a full
Rampage with his sandovistan and the
Cyber skeleton that he planted a while
back he was seemingly Invincible but
being Invincible isn't enough if you're
taking on the night City Boogeyman Adam
embodies the disrespectful and despising
Persona down to a team from his imposing
and menacing figure to his hatred of
fleshlings he's the complete package the
sole fact that he single-handedly
destroyed the main cast's plot armor by
killing not one but two major characters
in the most humiliating and gruesome way
just shows how much of a character this
guy is Rebecca was quite literally
squished to Red Mist and David was
basically disassembled lymph from them
using his bare hands the full Borg NC
Boogeyman Adam Smasher the one guy you
don't want to come across
dude
hello
coming up next we have the bird of
Hermes and Lord of Darkness himself
Alucard and his poor victim Luke
Valentine
when the Valentine Brothers launched a
series of attacks on the Helsing
organization Luke was ordered to take
out helsing's most dangerous dog Alucard
as the two vampires proceed to fight it
out Luke was getting a bit too cocky as
he proclaimed to Alucard now he's
Superior to him they were specifically
made to surpass and kill him now that
was kind of the case seeing as he was
clearly overpowering Alucard and
effortlessly Dodges all of alukan's
attacks but one restriction removal
scene later and the anime suddenly
changed its genre to horror breaking
Luke's fighting Spirit as countless
Horrors protrude from alucard's body
dismantling piece by piece breaking not
only his ego but also his body
all right
[Music]
foreign
's going up against foresight a worker
group that invaded nazarik us view is
already 100 know what fate entails for
this group of Merry thieves as they were
personally handled by mamonga himself by
that fact alone you already know they're
not making it out alive the best thing
they can hope for is to be taken as
slaves and pets for the denizens of the
great tomb back to the battle then Monga
didn't even acknowledge his enemies
seeing as he faced them only using
rudimentary weapons and basically Zero
armor showing up to the battle basically
topless as opposed to his endgame
overpowered gear not only that it wasn't
mentioned in the anime but apparently
that Connor he was wearing that one time
was actually a limiter that increases
exp gained however it lowers the user
stats not only did he put debuffs on
himself but he also wore low-tier
equipment irons didn't stop there
because he didn't just crush them around
he also crushed their Spirit by not even
letting art the mage of the group escape
she was later killed with her body
harvested for resources the group also
suffered the same gruesome fate as they
were dealt with one by one no mercy was
spared no hope was given let this be a
lesson the nun survives intact after
desecrating the great tomb of nazarik
foreign
why don't you give me your pick of these
moments are there any disrespectful
scenes that you think you're deserving
to be on this list be sure to share your
thoughts and I'll see you in the next
video